[Music]
feels like I've been walking
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast good morning to
everyone except Matt Lauer
happy Friday Friday gotta get down on
Friday we need to have Rebecca Black
like contract like on a contract here so
that she pops between the ferns every
Friday and just jams out for us or we
can just try and get her for a week
oh you just repulse me on Instagram I
think that would be like a great guess I
do think we are all booked for LA week
except maybe that one day you never know
like you never know always happen people
cancel like and people in LA just have
so much going on no it's actually so
crazy how hard it is to nail down talent
in LA seeing as how nobody has a job and
it's like they're so like flexible which
works in both ways like on the one hand
you don't know if anything's now down
but on the other hand when you need to
move something
everyone's available to move things yeah
because they're so flexible out there no
no it's so such silliness you know so
that's why we've been hesitant to
announce our guests because they keep
moving so I think we'll probably
announce to take forward like what we'll
we'll put up cards to get questions as
they are solidified yeah it's gonna be a
great week of guest and so I'm
rewatching Sex in the City and you know
like that one episode where they go to
LA and they're like la like the rings so
annoying yeah that's you you're like
pack is Park Lee trust me my Coto moving
for me I started planning my outfits
last night and like so morning as if I'm
going to a movie premiere every night
because like you never know like
technically that could happen a hundred
percent so I gotta say when you're
packing for a trip to Milwaukee like
that actually can't happen exactly I
know what you're saying I brought my
pink sparkly dress that I wore the
Billboard Music Awards like cuz you just
never know and it's a it's a city of
angels like maybe someone will be our
guardian angel and just Shepherd us to a
couple movie premieres yeah that's so
crazy well also I was doing some
research this morning maybe looking for
a concert we could go to that would be
like a fun thing
and I didn't find any but on the list of
concerts on Google my show did come up
which did feel really cool oh that's
pretty cool tickets available girls no
job com Sunday October 13th at the Ace
Theatre it's pretty cool it is pretty
nice I just feel like we're not gonna
like be in every night so we're I don't
know are we gonna be at hide like with
Kylie Khloe Lamar and Tyga
you weren't here on Monday for that
story but they were all Adam who
incidentally so it's obviously the place
to be but should we get a table at ha
this means that we have to be there
exactly so like make sure to pack your
hide clothes oh I mean that's that's my
Vegas the closet like that's a whole
other no you have to bring every cause
you have to bring New York you have to
bring Vegas you have to bring Los
Angeles and like I don't know like a
little bit of Dallas these boots I'm
having such a hard time packing like I
did a million orders online because I
hate shopping in real stores and it was
just all the orders were a bust and then
I was waiting for this ASOS order and I
checked my email my credit card was
declined so it never went through which
is the worst feeling I'm sorry ASOS you
shouldn't let the order be confirmed and
then unconfirmed it like the order never
should have been confirmed but know what
that happened to meet you when I was
shopping this summer for Zach and I
needed a so yeah in one day and I put in
my billing address wrong or something
and then the next like everyday counted
I was on like a one-day shipping
deadline of corn the next day they were
like oh this car didn't go through they
should not let you get an email
confirmation that the order went through
and then tell you that it's not
confirmed because the credit card like
check it in the beginning it's so
frustrating so today I'm gonna I'm gonna
head up some hoochie stores
I'm gonna go to see madam because I have
no shoes look what is the weather in LA
no and the thing about LA is like I feel
as though no one really dresses for the
weather which I appreciate but it's also
kind of hot so like you just don't want
to sweat but I was trying on the
craziest outfits yesterday like I was
putting like I've gotten some really
cool new pieces for fall and it hasn't
been cold enough here to like wear them
but I I guess they're perfect for LA
where it's 70 degrees it's so hot early
trying on like fur hats with a stole
like being insane I literally have like
one cute robber that I'm just gonna have
to wear every day yeah and then it's
like we're doing our show and so they
have to be like show clothes and then
we're gonna be like with doing other
people's shows and it's just like how do
I want their viewers to see me
no I don't know the ending vials podcast
like what to buy back for this podcast
and he films his podcast too right yes
and but it's like okie vibes so you know
what likes it like that pink wouldn't
match any trolls so you just you just
have so we're having a hard time so
today I gotta get my [ __ ] together I'll
be getting spray-tanned tonight I
totally forgot of yeah that'll change
things huge yesterday I spent two hours
shopping at Bloomingdale's and I got a
white t-shirt oh my god Bloomingdale's
was so treacherous yesterday like we
carried lugs of clothing into the
dressing room and left completely
empty-handed I bought one blouse just
because I couldn't have nothing to show
for it and it was a cute box and like
something new happened where usually I
buggle of stuff into the dressing room
and I'm hopeful and I'm just like you
know I can see some things working I
brought all this stuff into the dressing
room and like I hadn't no clue what I
even brought I was not excited about one
thing if I had to walk away from the
pile at that time like I totally
could've and I was right because nothing
was cute it was a wasteland up and there
you guys everything all they're selling
these days are sweaters yeah it's so hot
also I was like running around the store
fits in my dick off like literally so
much under room sweat just from like
carrying myself around the store in a
jacket carrying these logs look-alike
you think I want to try to sweater dress
yeah no no and I already got one here
why don't you talk about something
before we jump in because I watched e
true Hollywood story last night and so
it's like do you remember I think we
reported on the breath that they were
bringing back each Hollywood story and
it literally premiered last week like I
don't know what took them so long either
gotta get their facts right I appreciate
it and their first investigation was
into nexium which I appreciate it I do
wish it the thing I'd like waited till
next season because at the end it was
like it's ongoing
it's Allison Mac is awaiting sentence
Keith were near or waiting sense yes
Elizabeth Saltzman or whatever waiting
sentence Clair Bronfman awaiting
sentence and it's like okay so it's
incomplete
yeah that's frustrating but having said
that I need to talk about nexium for a
minute because I wish I kind of paid
more attention when I was in the news
because it's so crazy and they literally
they branded women which is the craziest
thing but what's most shocking is two
things one it's like what no one's
really talking about next to him it's
like it's a big group of losers they
talk about it like this Hollywood
whatever but like the coolest person
they got was alpha Mack and she was on
the TV show once 10 years ago and all
they wanted was to be this like cool
Scientology buy look that's what they
want
they were such like wannabes and the
only reason they got as far as they did
is because this woman Claire Brockman
who funded over 115 million dollars
that's how they were able to like be
this big presence but like nobody was he
was like ten people and again in Albany
like but because it got so alone because
they had so many resources and this one
woman left and she got sued for nine
years and she literate to file chapter
11 bankruptcy because Claire Branson's
money was being funneled into it and
they were just suing her because they
wanted to scare her like and the e true
Hollywood story and then they say it but
it really did a great job of just
showing how like it was really a nothing
burger like the three celebrities that
they had speaking to it one was this guy
Callum blue who I'd never heard of who
went to a meeting once in thought it was
weird and never came back then the most
the center of it was this woman I don't
remember her name but she was on the
original dynasty okay and her dog and
her daughter yeah like really got
involved it almost to the point where
she couldn't she got branded I getting
to the point where she couldn't be but
then the mom intervened and like those
were the celebrities and it was just
like it really highlighted how became
this huge news story it's like this
Hollywood like sex cult but like no one
famous was in it like yeah they were
lacking the one thing that like
Scientology necessarily like Hollywood
no like effects cult of all cults like
it wasn't the coolest one like it wasn't
the plastics it's no Scientology it's
what I'm saying yes it was like really
highlighting how much of like a looser
organization it wasn't like all these
women who like got tricked into it like
I know this is terrible to say but like
they were losers like because they do
you think you're just desperate like to
be it cárdenas like this except note it
was like a success program for
executives an executive ESP executives
success program something like that and
it was just like the way that and it
definitely really snowballed into what
it was like didn't just say you know
bring you in and then start branding
like it was really incremental yeah and
wash it listen the best clothes are yeah
but it was just like it was a conference
it's terrible to say but it was a cool
for losers I'm sorry
then and now I have to watch it I
thought it was it was so interesting and
the way that we were talking about it
like I was just like I was on a class it
was there and then next week is Kim yes
hm really and they have kids I thought
it already came out I thought it did too
busy in my youtube library
- I thought so I don't think so I
thought that's what I was watching is I
know the only one came out got it but
they have Kim and Kanye in it okay
and it's really they better go serving
up some fresh factoids cuz I like know
everything about Kim to the point where
it's getting a little redundant like I
know that like she has like weird toes
and her she is like a sense of smell and
she can't - she can smell in someone is
sick we also wanted it one more time
like someone's getting thick oh that's
actually so interesting one more thing
about nexium is they had like a cult
um expert and she was like saying what
defines the coals and like people are
always saying that we're a cult so first
she started talking and I'm like oh my
god we're a cult she was a cult you know
the most important thing about calls is
that it has you know charismatic leader
that's us okay and I was like oh my god
and that that you know people really
feel like they're safe in the community
and I was like holy [ __ ] I see and then
she was like and then you start
pretending that she lost me and that's
when I totally understood like we're not
a Colgate we have cultivars but I think
it's like that actually makes me feel
great cuz it's like we are what a cult
like what you join a cult to have like
the pros and without the branding yeah
yeah so what's that called like a
positive like it's called like the JCC
like no like a cult worth joint it's
called the sorority yeah that's true
yeah I just like I need to put it out in
the ethos how big of a loser this woman
Claire Brahmin was like and all these
pictures I kept using of her like she
looks like such a [ __ ] loser like
using her family's inherit it's one
hundred and fifty million dollars to
funnel a group losers like she's the
head loser I'm sorry I honestly what she
did is worth him or someone any of the
other people did really worse than the
one who was she had hashable
she made it possible she's the glue Zayn
she's the glue Zayn like she really to
me was the worst one got it and
aliceandmac like she's a like the head
loser in charge like she was HL I say
she was so desperate to be like a part
of Hollywood that like when when her
show got cancelled is when she joined
and like the fact that like she just she
was so desperate for some attention like
it was it was honestly like a really sad
documentary also someone just made a
great point the merch is our branding
branding we are I'm wearing the cropped
hoodie which has been restocked next
week super cute and I see oh I think
maybe that's what we should wear on
Nick's podcast
oh yeah we got a thirst out I got to
bring a ton of March yeah my laundry but
let's not match because then people will
think we're like weird okay like what
over sorry
that's right no we can't do that we're
like saying you wear something else okay
maybe I will
maybe I'll wear my disgrace queen did
you see how I cut it this week I did I
loved it it's so fashion-forward so I
ate a KitKat in my disgrace Queen shirt
last night and it's actually it's
ordered from our store another discreet
because I had a millennium that I cut a
little shorter and I ordered a small
that would be like cute with jeans maybe
I'll wear that on next podcast that way
like people know that we're self aware
that were like disgraced yeah but also
people but Queens nonetheless listen you
could call me a lot of things I mean you
can't not call me you can't call me not
software you know a hundred percent of
software I'm disgraced like wonderful
and you know what it's like you know
what it's like it's like what snitch was
saying oh you weren't here when Nick
vile came on the show Dean had been on
his show and he was saying he got like
this most wonderful edit on Rachel
season everyone thought he was like the
golden child so much anxiety because he
was like that's not who I am and so it's
like yeah the bar is so low for us it's
wonderful yeah that is actually so true
I mean also I was just inspired maybe
I'm for an x Mart shop like a cool you
know design that says culty vibes called
events only I don't know if we should
I'd lean into the cult like stigma of
like why not yeah I don't know well
we'll have to do it we'll have to a be
test that yeah cool well I'm glad you
want to hide I'm definitely gonna check
it out we both watched Real Housewives
so we'll recap that late yes Dallas and
OC and just real I think that I forgot
to put on deodorant that's the worst
feeling yeah that's a bad feeling
especially in a cashmere turtleneck
what's good what's [ __ ] good um it's
time it's time it's for sure time for
for the past five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
snitch is also not here she's taking one
more day off because she's sick and we
are heading to LA tomorrow and I was
such a good sister I had her eye soup
delivered to her I really don't want her
to be sick like first of all she's a
misery when she's sick we're gonna spend
a week in a hotel room with her like her
like selfishly I don't want to be
anywhere near a sick snitch it she's the
worst
I'm also I just want her to be sick you
know yes selfless person and we need her
like working hard so she had to be
taking those vitamins and getting her
[ __ ] together
she's been on care of I think she
actually used our code to get started
she's now she's her own code I know
she's branched out she's high on that
ashwagandha if you love something set it
free right if it ever loved
you it'll start using your code again so
Karen makes it easy to see where to see
where they source their ingredients from
and ensure only the highest quality
products so basically it's super hard to
get your daily Justin vitamins like with
all those bottles and like that pill
thing it's just not the right and it
wasn't really down with the idea of
vitamins just cuz like it takes up too
much space on my counter until I heard
about carob actually heard about it from
Lord bushnell's Instagram story like a
couple years ago and that's when I
ordered it and basically it comes once a
month and it comes like little packets
you know you take a little packet it
comes to slim tall box you take a packet
and has your daily dose of vitamins you
take a quiz online before asking what
kind of like symptoms you have what you
want to improve on obviously something I
wanted to improve on was brain activity
and like brain function and memory
because that's something I definitely
struggle with also just like general
like bowel movements I get really page
in suggestion you could do memory you
can do I do like building strength
oh yeah that's a friend so then after
you put the put together they ask if you
are like into like Eastern no you
certain yeah
Eastern you know alternative methods or
if you want to stick to like classic
stuff and then at the end they put
together a like five or six elicits oh
five or six vitamins for you and they
send you in little packets so every day
you just run in your purse great for
travel I'm throwing I'm on it in my
suitcase for this weekend it's it's
super great they care about the
environment and with their new
compostable pots they made the same
quality and safety standards and they
have a ton of info on how they can post
them on their website they're vegan and
vegetarian supplement options are
available to match your dietary needs
and to ensure you're getting the
nutrients you need for those specific
diets um if you want to take care of
yourself 25% off your first care of
order go to take care of calm enter the
code toast again for 25% off your first
care of order go to take care of comm
and enter the code toast the quiz is fun
and easy and taking care of your body
it's priceless so just it's not
everybody's also can be fun and easy and
also you're just taking care of business
you know taking care of business right
that's a great way it's a great way that
MADD also sign-on take care of yourself
no sign-on take care of sign-on get
taken care of okay okay well without
further ado we got the past five stories
for you I say there's a roughly three
that you absolutely need to know and the
first one is the most pertinent to the
situation I know if you were about to
turn off the show
stay put I posted about this on our
Instagram today liam hemsworth holds
hands with dining these dynasty star
Kirby Andrews aka Madison what are what
website is this paycheck
okay so TMZ have the nerve to just refer
to her son Australian actress like as if
she's not on the most prestigious
primetime show first I saw on Instagram
some like gossip site referred to as
mystery woman oh well you know what
low-key that actually makes me feel
better for like any time no one's like
known who I am cuz I think I'm the [ __ ]
but in like the grand scheme the world I
would absolutely no but absolutely
nobody
it's like Madison Bradley she's on TV
and she's still a mystery woman totally
so hard out here for us women mysterious
women were so mysterious now it appears
that Liam Hemsworth is moving on amid
his divorce from Miley Cyrus The Hunger
Games star with spotting holding hands
with dynasty actress Madison Brown in
the West Village this week according to
photos obtained by TMZ Hemsworth 29 in
brown 22 dine alfresco at celebrity
mainstays st. Ambrose great taste these
two halves holy and they took the subway
Brown who also hails from Australia and
place Kirby Andrews Anders on the CW
reboot kept her look casual with Keynes
a pattern blouse and black booties okay
she looked really cute and casual like
what do you wear when you're dating the
sexiest man alive like I don't know and
for her it's probably like such a big
deal because like he's how does man
alive but he's also like from her home
country so there's like a lot of pride
there and I just think like of all the
people he could have rebounded with like
who better who better like what a choice
he has amazing rebound girls do you
remember when him and Miley broke up
temporarily when they were like
teenagers and then he was like spotted
at the gym with a second's Ollis who
turned out to be like the next biggest
superstar in the world
and like it's so beautiful so he has a
great taste in women other than Miley
Miley's great to it but no I totally
agree and as a dynasty fan like this is
so exciting because it's just gonna get
more eyeballs on the show totally
disappearance
yeah but like now everyone's gonna be
like oh Liam's like girlfriends show
like I gotta check it out and then
they're obviously gonna be hooked
because it's the greatest show ever
which returns tonight on the CW and ie
yes and I'm so [ __ ] excited I'm gonna
watch it on the plane tomorrow okay me
too I mean I wish this NASA was here she
said she's probably dying
yeah did you see her watching her gerta
asked me oh my god is that directly
Cryer and her thing I guess they did a
tribute episode for the first episode
back the season yet that prefers Lee
Perry for Fred Andrews and I don't
really watch every day so I thought it'd
be weird if I just like watch like the
only sad episode but
is like in an emotional state that she
might not recover from yeah I'm really
feeling for her I like to bundle my
Riverdale episodes together because it
takes a while for me to get into it so I
don't want to like get into my chest for
it to be over so I need like four
episodes at a time also like Netflix and
the streaming services have ruined like
week to week shows for me for scripted
shows like reality shows I can live with
week to week it's not like I'm dying to
see what happens but I Blue Bloods I
have like three episodes now because I
just can't get behind like watching what
an hour every week it's so silly like I
can't leave people back in the day I
used to watch a 22 minute episode of
friends every other week that's okay
it's great also we really discussed blue
bloods being taken off of Netflix cuz I
know you don't really care but I just
want to say it's a travesty
shame on you it'll probably be I'm one
of the new streaming services but it's
CBS what is it gonna be they have a
streaming service coming out now maybe
they're partnering with someone Viacom
they're Viacom right I don't know I
don't know man
it's just awful like I just everything
is changing and I wish it would it yeah
I'm sorry for you but I'm so happy for
Madison Brown and Liam Hemsworth and
like I couldn't have dreamed up a better
couple you know I mean like sat here
dreaming up a couple for him and like we
couldn't and if we had all day to like
you know take every female celebrity I
never would have thought that it's in
brown and that's why it's so perfect
that's my super she's Australian she's
beautiful and honestly I'm liking like
she's almost like the female version of
cookie City Oh underrated very
good-looking Australian and like a great
match for Miley or lib yeah and they're
both from down under
Down Under and I think he loves it Down
Under and I think so does she cause she
even plays in Australian on dynasty so
that was obviously important to her even
if she has a lot of like home where she
just couldn't shake her accent you know
I was also just looking at her Instagram
like she's always posting that's it and
they like it's her home yes so they
obviously have so much in common
total addition to being good-looking and
I really hope this isn't just like a
rebound relationship like I hope there's
some real severity to it there better be
some severity to it this is so great
like everyone's happy you know and like
I hate when in a breakup like it's so
obvious that someone wins you know and
like Miley's out here just like posting
everything Cody Cody Cody and like
posting cryptic Instagram stories like
I'm so glad I can finally do what I want
make it seem like maybe Liam was
controlling like but I feel as though
all of those stories were actually
starting to swing in the other direction
where like now she's been in two serious
relationships since her divorce which is
still not file
he's like a month ago and it's starting
to raise some red flags for me
personally it just gotta say I'm
actually you know what I kind of feel
like um I was just watching Sex in the
City I know I keep saying this and
Charlotte was like you have to devote
the four break-up time you have to
devote 50% of how long the relationship
was so if you were dating for a year you
have six months to get over him and I
actually thought that was like so untrue
like you need a day to get over someone
like oh no like I can especially like
the longer the relationship I feel like
this shorter like like if Miley and Liam
were together for so long and like it
obviously was you know troubling at the
end like by the time it finally ends
like you're ready to go well I think no
I mean that's a nice idea but that's
just not how people work I heard that
when you're in a longer relationship
once it's over you're more you want to
get your life back and you just lost ten
years of your life if you had a bad
experience so you just want to like get
going with the time that you do have but
it takes time and I actually do think
that's how I used to feel about camp
when I would get home from camp and I
was I was Kim sick and I didn't um I was
like getting adjusted back to home life
I was like okay I was I came for eight
weeks so I think in four weeks this will
feel normal
yeah well counts did my first breakup
camp is the depression of coming home
from camp was something I really
struggled with at a young age and then
like you probably have lice I think
that's just like and it makes it worse
it make it worse right because it's like
oh I'm back to sleeping in my bed but
I'm sleeping with oil in my hair right I
guess I'm not alone with all the lice in
my hair well it's still happy for these
two everyone just seems to be on a great
page in this relationship and until
something changes I'm very happy with
where we are very happy with where we
and this must just be like a great
moment for Madison Brown like her shows
wearing and she's more famous than ever
you know mm-hmm I'm excited for her it's
gonna be good yeah I'm excited for
dynasty okay you ready for our next
story which is some exciting news but
also a little troublesome
well not this news is in trouble some
but then then I suppose Drew Barrymore
is getting a daytime talk show yeah I
saw it's official drew Barrymore will
host a daytime talk show slated to
premiere in fall 2020 CBS television
distribution which will produce the
syndicated series announced
formal order on Thursday reports of
Barrymore's foray into daytime
television had been in circulation since
the show's pilot was shot in August oh
it is beyond my wildest dreams to have
this opportunity for a daily talk show
she said the statement
I'm truly thrilled and honored to be
creating this show with CBS okay so it's
good I mean she's so likable on its own
it's good yeah but now we're getting
into a place where there are so many
celebrity daytime talk shows and they're
just like throwing a lot of [ __ ] against
the wall not every time most talk shows
actually aren't successful no but this
is also just like how I feel about like
the podcasting medium it's like
celebrities infiltrating every [ __ ]
like medium where it's like how can
regularly how can just Giuliana Rancic
like who started as a host I can end up
with her own show like that's not a
possibility anymore because chemical
arcs and intro Barrymore just waltzing
in and taking the shows yeah but I feel
like celebrities who get their own shows
it never worked like thing I never get
more than two seasons so this time I
mean look at Chris Wright this might be
nice can't do it no one can
this is like a trend that like was
happening 5 years ago and now it's like
resurgent it's researching um I thought
the Chris daytime show it was such a
good idea right but if that didn't work
and the set being her house like genius
then no one stands a chance so right now
we have Kelly Clarkson we have Jerry Oh
show we're gonna have drew Barrymore
like we had busy fill up yes and they're
not working and they're go to Jerry OH
it tested on Fox and then I didn't hear
anything I was good I don't know if he
worked so hard on it like he deserves a
second season I know but I don't know
what makes for a good daytime talk show
write it series so it's interesting what
sticks and what doesn't yeah it's just
like this whole thing's a little
frustrating with just celebrities like
waltzing into jobs that they're not
necessarily qualified for and that
people who actually like work really
hard at like like Meredith Vieira had to
work forever until she got her own show
and like then it was cancelled you know
yeah Meredith Vieira ran so Kelly
Clarkson could jog no but Meredith yeah
like it's not the same but Meredith
Vieira came up as a host yeah so it's
not the same but it's like Tyra walked
so Kelly could run actually that's what
Tyra show was good I know why did it go
off the air and it was a while I mean it
was like a failure but anything that
ends on TV is like inevitably yeah
considered a failure but I don't
consider Tyra Banks to show a fail
because it was poppin I walk down to
that swimsuit that was everything yeah
but then it's like Wendy Williams is
such a success but she is a host she's
famous for like celebrities being hot
like I and I guess Ellen is the
celebrity who became the host but now
she's like such a host Oh like she was
on a TV show sitcom yes yeah but she was
like hardly famous back then no but like
she became a star because of the talk
time the daytime talk chat but still
daytime talk show but still yeah she's a
celebrity before that yeah it's Harry
Connick Jr can't do it there's no hope
for anyone else we got tickets to the
Harry Connick jr. show like the day it
was canceled membrane yeah I don't
remember that someone else office we
wanted to go home I said yeah so I mean
as much as I'm so excited for Drew
Barrymore in like this has nothing to do
with her like I know probably a year
from now we'll be reporting then it's no
more ya know and I'd like to marry more
and for somebody's in like this just
this tastes a little bitter than Kelly
Clarkson cuz I don't know come the idea
of Kelly Clarkson having a show like I
know she's gonna be on TV for 30 years
like I just know it like there's no
doubt in my mind her she's so good and I
just there was something about like the
announcement and like Drew Barrymore
gives me that same vibe which is like
very maternal she's hilarious
I saw her speak somewhere once and I
fell in love with her like I read her
book like she is she's it but I'm not
something about this just feels like a
little cheap yeah like you know she's
like part of a big Hollywood family like
she got it because of that like I don't
know I'm like I'm bitter for sure I had
but things like I love Kelly Clarkson
her show is great like she gives
everything to it I literally get PR
announcements like I don't know what
[ __ ] email distros I'm on I guess the
most annoying emails but I get like her
PR roundup and it sounds like she's
doing great things i watch her clips all
the time Kelly okey that's really cute
but like I don't I won't be like I'm not
gonna be I will be more surprised if it
goes for 10 years then if next month
we're saying it's over I don't think so
I think she has longevity it's not about
her
no it's but it's about the whole set the
set up like I think she came in at an
ideal time where like there really has
been a lull now it's like a bunch of
other things popping up but I haven't
heard about a new Big Show she literally
the network put everything behind her
I've seen her out every [ __ ]
billboard everybody so every Twitter
promoted add like true color there no
they're trying to make it work and I
think it's working
yeah okay I hope it's working so I hope
that it works for Drew Barrymore because
like that sounds like a wonderful show I
don't watch daytime right so I cannot
participate in making this as a success
or a failure I can do as much from the
sidelines daytime talk shows are so
fickle and fleeting just like bachelor
friendships and I have to say and I
don't really watch daytime but when I do
I've watched Ellen and we grudgingly
loved it and I've also watched Wendy and
also loved it yeah okay next story I'm
so excited to talk about Kylie Jenner's
office tour inside Kylie Jenner's
offices roses made of dollars a playroom
for stormy personalized M&Ms and lots of
self-portrait the billionaire mogul
gives a tour of her extravagant Kylie
cosmetics headquarters she you know
anytime she uploads to YouTube I want to
support and I want to follow because I
just want more content so I don't want
to be too negative but it was incredibly
boring and she was having a hard time
getting her words out and she was like
this is just like another example of
like me using my products lection that's
art honey time to get [ __ ] say that
and also like where are the desks it was
how many square feet you think that was
like 10,000 like a million and one and
there were just like four offices
including her and Chris's like where how
many people actually work for Kylie
cosmetics
I don't know but I didn't think there
was a lack of desk she had the cubicles
at Kylie skin and then she had offices
at Kylie cosmetics making also she
wasn't gonna show you people's desks
because their personal spaces know for
sure but like everyone who works there
okay so that's what we can do everyone
who works for Kylie cosmetics has it
office know their MA there must be an
area with them with Dennis market dad
and think she would be like judge yeah
but nothing about that office is sad all
I felt was like I mean it was kind of
boring but I couldn't literally watch
her just stand there which is what we
did in that Chanel dress that Chanel
dress she was so out of breath honestly
giving a tourists heart no but like I
don't like at every turn she was just
like I felt like she was catching her
breath and it's like take your time what
do you think she was drinking who I
don't know I think it was you who you
think it looked like you who I didn't
even try and figure it out it's probably
like some tea like some kombucha it was
very very interesting
was hilarious and I thought she didn't
want to show it because she's like like
to blur out sponsors mm-hmm but no
that's even funnier yeah more authentic
um the office is literally a dream she
has a [ __ ] room for everything oh
this is my conference room for my team
and this is my conference room for my
family and I love it she like her family
is such a big part of like what she
built there but the fact that she has a
glam room for like friends and family
and then we're like a glam room for
everyone and then a glam room for her
it's so crazy well so then this begs the
question do they have offices out of
this like cuz it seems like she got an
office and everyone uses it so they used
to have Jenner communications yeah do
they still have that I don't think so I
don't think so either I think Kris works
out of her house and out with her few
assistants no and she works out of Kylie
cosmetics right but still like k'kaw do
they have a business in office like okay
a good American probably as an office
but that's not like Chloe's office
that's yeah a Nordstrom company I guess
they don't or maybe they do and like but
Kim's not a youtuber so we would never
know like we only know that Kylie has an
office now because they did that episode
of Keeping Up they did drunk get ready
with me yeah and it's just because I
Kylie so but like I feel no she was just
making it seem like everyone uses it
because nobody I mean there's no doubt
in my mind that Kourtney doesn't have an
office and probably Chloe either Chris
uses Kylie and so Chris is most like the
CFO of Kylie so she's not using a
natural but I'm sure she uses it for
things outside of Kylie 100 they had
meetings in that conference room but I
just wanna know if Kim has one I feel
like she has - yes - well so it's just
probably not a chic no or it's just
she's like super proud like she's very
not like private in the sense of she
doesn't show us much but like
security-oriented yeah also in the each
other with story they go deep into Paris
yeah hopefully there's some new factoids
but like it's just so sad it's just how
do you do an e true Hollywood story
about someone who you know everything
about you have to give us new things
yeah and that's why they have her and
Kanye but to make it special
yeah I'm really excited I'm loving the
new like each Hollywood story I'm like
obsessed with her now I'm so excited we
need to get offices now that I've seen
Kylie's but like I was trying to think
of how much this must cost like per
month for them oh my god like $30,000 a
month oh I was singing 50 or maybe a
hundred because we looked at office
spaces and we saw a corner in the wall
for $10,000 a month and more like are
you kidding no it was you guys there
no windows and it was four grand a month
it looks like one option that was a two
desk option it was so terrible no
Williams no it's there's no wonder that
we work is filing for bankruptcy because
they're criminals
the whole sowing is insane in real
houses of Dallas when they were talking
about the entrance office being eight
thousand dollars a month like that's
what it costs in Dallas her office is
nice you know she is like real offices
and it just made me realize like we have
to move I know we have to move no
brother I was thinking texting you
yesterday about that oh my god please
any like literally no behaving I think
I'm moving to an office who me no -
another see my bags are packed I'm ready
to go move to another state I'm sorry Jo
I will go anywhere you could pick
anywhere in the world like boys ooh done
let's go
I know I actually would love to live in
Boise know was like I would like I'm
literally not kidding like we could have
an office we could like move to a farm
come in and have like a barn studio oh
my god okay also do you know the dough
infants are like I know their name okay
so they came up on my youtube homepage
and there was it was like moving on time
to move out I saw this in the morning -
it was one hour long and I definitely
skipped about 45 minutes of it and to be
honest I don't know what they announced
basically that they're not gonna do
weekly videos anymore there's gonna like
vlog when they want a vlog not because
they have to cause any blogging every
day every Tuesday for five years and it
was incredibly dramatic dad's like sit
down with the therapist like it was kind
of silly and but the most important part
was that they had built a studio in
their house and they said it was like
honestly really hard on them like making
it like your house feel like your work
and like no separation yeah and honestly
like if we ever thought to do that like
I like it was I was cured in that moment
yeah and they took it down they were
like I'm why we have a living room but I
feel like for us it would be different
because it's just the two of us you know
it's not like when they had lady gang
then they had like 30 people and true
yeah YouTube team yeah yeah so still I
don't think I would ever do it no I mean
no one's giving us that option so yeah I
think it's fine um you know what I was
realizing when I was watching Kylie
storm mmm she has a collection with
every sister except for Kendall because
Kendall is a face of Estee Lauder she
had to make up club right that makes
sense yes pretty cool that sucks
Kenna doesn't do clubs with anything
that like well cuz to be honest okay if
Kendall did ask in sclab like nobody
would buy it because
since she's literally a piece of paper
and even like good American well they
don't good American doesn't do clouds at
the same time like I don't want jeans
I don't need jeans that can hold up
Kendall Jenner's ass I need you
technical up close yeah but like so her
jeans
no offense like wouldn't be for you it
would be for like you know like 18 year
olds who like her butt cheeks hanging
out which I don't think is maybe like a
good Americans never grab Nick what's
yeah and then she could do a club with
Courtney's company but there's just so
many think she's passionate about she's
yeah I was actually just re watching our
Halloween episode and then was so funny
it's like when you do so good like it
puts a lot of pressure like after our
first Halloween episode I'm glad we felt
last year and by the way when we had the
idea to be like Kim and Kourtney like we
weren't that we didn't feel that
strongly I how do you want to dive into
it I thought it was like late yeah you
did and it was the success yeah no it's
like no you make it but now it's like
even more cuz like okay I'm like now we
can't be Kim and Chloe or Courtney of
course we can't know we can't know why
would that's not even an option what are
we being you know aware be I know I'm
like nervous about it but it's gonna be
great it's gonna be hilarious yeah
we have full makeup artist like we need
to find like Tokyo Styles to do our hair
okay it's gonna be really funny and I've
seen a lot of people guessing what they
think we're gonna be ya seen it I
haven't seen it either and it's not that
um it's not that crazy but people think
we're gonna be like housewives I'll be
boring should I tell them what we were
gonna be which one from what I got along
yeah I they know who you are gonna be
the twin peach and pear from what a girl
I'm gonna sit here for an hour and big
wigs we would just say this she is so
nice but honestly I don't know if that
reference is like universal enough it's
just too nice our show around I know and
every story it would be this she is so
nice that is so funny idea I would have
liked that too we had some really funny
ideas we'll share them after or maybe
well there were some that were like
evergreen that we could do like you know
yeah we're who my sister Mathilda oh I
told you that yeah miss changeable
excuse me miss charge Bob honey Matilda
I shouldn't
yeah now why would I have to be Miss
Trunchbull like I know why but like I
just great yeah much stupid you would be
great yeah I would you could tell down
broad right your time you could bring
your shot put and javelin yes I've been
meaning to get my chaplain out of my
closet you really on the third storey
anyway that's the second time we've said
license today's episode she is so okay
yeah third story was Kylie cosmetics I
told you there was only three that you
really need to know the fourth one is
exciting it's only really half the story
because I haven't gotten to read the
article yet but Rihanna is on the cover
of Vogue oh okay here's what you need to
know I watch Knightley pop here's what
you need to know she was offered the
Super Bowl last year and put and turned
it down turn it down thank you I
couldn't speak the word and now a lot of
people are saying like the timing of the
article associated - JLo and Shakira
being like I wouldn't do it so JLo can
but it's important to know that this
article was in the interview happened in
August before the announcement for sure
also like Briana's not JD like that no
she's not calculated like she does
things she doesn't like plan her move
she's really passionate and she stands
with Colin Kaepernick and such went to
the Super Bowl and good for her for
having principles I admire that to the
person who was interviewing Rihanna
didn't know that she was interviewing
Rihanna and quote-unquote winged it and
then tweeted about it now people are
really upset like okay you're gonna wing
it don't [ __ ] say it we're gonna get
one interview in five years and you're
gonna [ __ ] wing it yeah no it was
really late it's beautiful on the cover
it's very hen mates tell buddy yes
Jackie is she yeah she said so proud to
be on another cover of Vogue magazine
wearing my own designs from Fendi on
stands October 16 she also just
announced that she's coming out of the
book it's like a it's a picture book
it's like a thousand images the life of
a pop star and that's gonna be wildly
interesting hey that came Kardashian it
that's true and I think that was all the
the Wharton noteworthy moments from the
article I mean she's back like she took
a lot of time off and build your
business and now she's like in the news
more than ever now and I really did miss
her I miss her too and now I need to
read the article because there's
definitely way more interesting factoids
and it's like I don't care what like the
publication's like pick up from it like
whatever like overarching story it's
like it's all in the little nuggets you
know I was watching Knightley pop last
night and it was actually great episode
because he's talked about a lot of the
stories we spoke
like Ellen and spoke about this and I
just like loved hearing their
perspectives that's why I love watching
daily pop like I just like we got we
come on the show and we essentially wing
it and then I'm like okay what are the
experts thing so and then they were
talking about did you see um sophie
turner did that instagram video with
like the lip you know the new filter on
instagram stories with the lips yeah
she's like i'm an influencer and like i
sell tea that gives you diarrhea even
though I shouldn't because I love money
and like it was like funny I guess and
like I couldn't really decide how I felt
about it cuz I gotta love Sophie Turner
and Morgan Stewart like perfectly
vocalize like what was wrong with this
video she's like I love Sophie Turner
but like this video fell flat like I get
the message like it wasn't funny
like I there's something really weird
about the video I didn't see the video
but I feel as though because you just
summed it up great it's just like
low-hanging fruit it's like a joke
that's been made a million times
Sophie Turner's like so much more
elevated that then that like she makes
her own jokes like and that's the tea
yeah I like to go for the jugular and
like the kind of influencers that like
sell tea for money that gives you
diarrhea like they're they're not
actually influential right like that's
why they're selling tea right and then
they would be on their mouth trip made
the most amazing point and she said and
I kind of have a problem with people
like sophie Turner and Jameela Jamil who
are like universally like beautiful and
skinny like they've never been marketed
at dieting and been like intrigued you
know I mean it was like I struggle with
my weight my whole life and I know what
it's like to see an ad like promises
you're gonna lose weight like and think
about it like you know and it's like all
these people like speaking up for us
it's like please don't like symphonies
hurting you don't you don't speak for me
it's such a brilliant point like I don't
think anyone should be promoting team
but like seeing all these skinny people
like complaining about it like please
like let me try the today okay I know
100% but at this point like we all know
that she is guard that he doesn't work
so like so when people keep promoting
and it's like wow
what are you doing but it's a member
when came posted those appetite
suppressing larlie yes
and Jameela Jamil went off and it's like
no one actually had actually I guess
it's still part of like that fit T
community yeah but it was the first time
we were seeing them and that's how I
felt I was like I'm a hungry [ __ ] like
an appetite suppressant that's like
being sold not on the black market like
yeah okay I know I know it was like a
controversial statement but I
appreciated Nina Parker bringing like a
different perspective to the
conversation and one in which I kind of
agreed with like I've been tempting them
in my life to like try something crazy
and it's like all these people like who
are very skinny and healthy like telling
me that I should I'm like oh okay
like I don't know just like how do I
know how to feel and I appreciated Nina
Parker like bringing an alternative
perspective right and these people who
can hire like chefs and trainers to make
sure they don't like step out of line
right yeah okay I kind of want to watch
the episode now but I still have sophie
Turner and Jamila Jamila Sui Stan oh for
sure but it's always nice you know have
another perspective yeah this is the
final story a little Matt Lauer update
because things are going from bad to
worse actually from worse to even worse
for this guy NBC's Today Show colleague
spoke to People magazine with some
damning claims he they said that Matt
Lauer was known for engaging and
inappropriate relationships with junior
staffers and punishing those who
rejected his advances quote I wish I
could say any of it surprised me but it
doesn't I guess I'm a little surprised
that he still doesn't get it that he
still thinks it was okay to have quote
affairs with co-workers who had
absolutely every reason to feel nervous
if they didn't find his attentions
flattering the source says if you didn't
find his flirting behavior charming and
just using the word flirting feels wrong
because it was so much more predatory
than right and it was not harmless then
you put a target on your back totally
it's like he's so like in his own world
of disgusting this that like he thinks
that when he's advancing on to like his
younger co-workers that he's flirting
with them but like that's not how it
comes off because huge or how it is
right you're an intern and you walk in
and the boss famous boss wants to talk
to you and he puts his hand on your
thigh like that's not flirting that's
like oh [ __ ] yeah like it's very
different that's oh [ __ ] yeah that's
[ __ ] territory if you didn't find his
comments about a or your weight loss or
your beautiful eyes to be funny or
flattering if you dared to say was
inappropriate or worst of all asked him
to please not say it again then you were
either dead to him like you really
became invisible or worse you were
someone he'd talk about in negative
terms quote she's so uptight she's not a
team player she's really uncooperative
she's got a terrible work ethic you were
either able to be one of the guys with
him or you were in jeopardy I mean
everything that comes out about Matt
Lauer is just worse and worse
it's like and he has he still doesn't
get it that's like he's still like
releasing statements he's still trying
to like come back from this I think he
does still think he's gonna work again
and I think he realizes he's dead in the
ground sit down and stay seated sit down
and just literally shut up and like he
hasn't enough money to just let live so
it's not even about like cancelling
someone it's like you created a toxic
workplace environment you succeeded in
that environment for decades like sit
the [ __ ] down it's someone else's turn
now
yeah it's like take the Kevin Spacey
approach like fall off the face of the
earth please and only show up for your
court hearings okay yeah oh so that
actually begs another question I would
love to hear your opinion on this
because in the in the council culture
there's one person who's like trajectory
has really confused me and that's Louie
CK because what he did was horrifying
like I I include it with some of the
worst of the worst but for some reason
like people are giving him a pass he's
still doing shows like very small
underground but like he's getting slowly
getting back to work okay well I think
there's a dip like he can be doing shoes
shows in like if people and his fans
like want to choose to buy tickets like
I think that's fine no one's really like
given with him no one's like propping
him up giving him this this platform but
he a P that's if he earns it like say he
doesn't like a comedy special or
something it's because enough people
have bought tickets to be shows and
enough of his fans and audience people I
don't care about what he did I know but
that's crazy because what he did was bad
it's like Kevin Spacey can't be in
another movie because that would be
someone giving him like a also half an
hour that be giving him that chance it's
not the people who are deciding do you
know what I mean yeah I guess but like
even like a Netflix if they ever were to
like gave louis c.k and yes there was
demand for it like to me that just seems
wrong like what it did was bad no and I
don't think that like a Netflix would
but um it's like when if it's gonna make
them money and enough right people don't
want to cancel an ACK accused of
masturbating in front of people like
whipping out his penis
in front of people like it's so weird
first of all like I would literally like
never whip out my vagina like so weird
it's so personal
no it's like it's not it's not good so
yeah he's just like I feel like he toes
the line because
there's like we said yesterday there's
huge difference in Kensal culture
between people who do bad things and
people who say yeah but he did bad
things right and then like not treating
the quarter you can be arrested for
indecent exposure so like he's illegal
he's committed crimes right but for some
reason like he I have a feeling he will
be back and maybe bigger than ever
really bigger than ever yeah interesting
he's like slowly making is where I would
say like anything I can do like he did a
show in Paris he went to a comedy club I
did a show I'm sorry to cut you off I
did a show in some comedy club and I was
just talking to the manager there and he
was like yeah we had lose kick come in
last week like the place was packed like
everyone stood up when he walked out I
was like what and yet someone saying the
big news are giving him a chance know
the venue's our businesses and they want
to make money and if Louie CK wants to
come to their club somewhere like years
ago he probably wouldn't have because he
was so big like they're interested in
their own bottom line as they should be
you know people are gonna show up for
this guy like okay yeah no the guy said
he had never seen the bar so full in his
life that's really crazy and they feel
like the comedy community also doesn't
really know how to feel about it like
cuz they're so irreverent colleagues
yeah you know I was like some of them
are talking about it in Howard Stern's
book were they yeah and they like they
felt conflicted because they like they
didn't know but they were like I should
have how do you not know this about
someone that you're so close with but
then also like in the Dave Chappelle
special he was kind of making the
argument that was he not that big of a
deal he's not that big of a deal but I
think I wholeheartedly disagree with
that like the joke was funny I guess but
like no what he did was [ __ ] crazy
and weird I'm like he shouldn't work
again
he's a Kevin Spacey to me but he's not
being treated like one I don't know I
mean I don't want to like to start like
comparing crying Rose it's like it's all
bad but Kevin Spacey I he's actually not
a captain of Spacey to make because what
Kevin Spacey did in the grand scheme of
like all the canceled culture is the
worst like rape like molestation of
young boys agreed agreed agreed agreed
and he's on Jeffrey Epstein level yeah
yes Jeffrey yeah and like I think
they're they're definitely like
different layers of but it's all bad
it's all yeah yeah but no that isn't
interesting an interesting factoid yeah
and I could see that like him just like
guy not in the comedy space like
just hear about him all the time like
more than you hear about a person who
should have just like been cancelled for
good you know yeah but also I don't know
but then it's like now I'm gonna
contradict myself but it's like what
Jameela Jamil said like you can grow you
all grow and change in like yes should
you be canceled forever I don't know but
it's just I just go in extreme so I'm
like he's very pissed and and she said
something right sometimes there's
someone in the middle who just pulled
out their penis right a bunch of times
and masturbated in front of people which
is not cool no oh but it's like here and
if you're a podcast listener I'm doing a
bet right it's on the specs on the grand
scheme of the world that we live in like
what what louis c.k did like isn't that
shocking because what Kevin Spacey and
Jeffrey Epstein and like Harvey
Weinstein did it's like so much worse
but it's still in you know it's that's
moral relativism yeah Wow I can't wait
that phrase um but it is because still
what Louis K did was illegal disgusting
a predatory yes so I'm gonna think about
yeah and there should be consequences
for his actions agreed let's recap Real
Housewives of Dallas and Orange County
let's start with Orange County wrapped
up near of all they're back home what
happened oh what happened it was so
boring Alexis Bellino showed up June and
Emily are fighting about the day soft
spot in my heart for Alexis Bellino I
like her justice for Alexis Bellino she
sees her for way back I'm here for it
like it looks like she's in a good
relationship and great and I would I
would be here for it and it's
interesting because she was like at her
height when she was on the show she was
you know at her peak in her marriage
with Jim and they were like so superior
they felt like they were acted superior
everybody is a temple and she went
through all of the lows that a lot of
women go through on the show all of the
show and now we're seeing her again and
she's like in that Chan in place of
being feeling really great yeah so it's
like we didn't have to go through any of
the torture with her and now we just get
to see like only the good stuff and
she's very cute and she seems like a
good friend I had no idea her and Emily
even knew each other and this episode
just like was really difficult for me to
watch because I for some reason like I'm
so weird like with housewives like have
you come on and you rubbed me the wrong
way like I'll never forgive you like I
just I just don't like you and for some
reason like Emily like I feel for her
like I really do I don't know maybe I
like relate to her in some way like
something about her like
like warms my heart like I want to help
her like in the fact that her and
scheana are not fighting again and do I
think the chief knew that chance cousin
had a boyfriend no like it's just so
silly like she can't seem to get out of
she finally was in a good place with
everyone like now she's back and
everyone's talking [ __ ] about her time I
was like it she started to like Emily
like I just she can't get her feet out
of the ground I agree and I do feel for
her and a lot of aspects and I will say
when she was on the date with Jeana and
her husband I thought that Shane was
being like adorable normal and now I'm
like okay maybe they're not getting
divorced Jackie same he like finally
left the house and something clicked
like something clicked and it's like his
humor was landing yeah and it wasn't
like it was coming off like semi-normal
he was giving good advice totally a grin
I saw their relationship as something
different than what I've been seeing I
policies in which I was grateful for me
too as far as the cuz maybe she didn't
know that the cousin had a girlfriend
but she should have known agreed so like
what are you doing setting your friend
up who's like so [ __ ] fragile no
totally but this is the same this is a
sentiment of like no good deed goes
unpunished
you know like I'm sure she just wanted
to help and she got but you must have a
good deed yeah that maybe just like if
someone needs to go on a date with
someone like the only requirement is
that they're single look do a little bit
in the breathing so either
you knew and you send him on the date to
make you feel better which is like not a
friend to my do and you just gave it a
half-ass effort right so like yeah I
just like I can't get on Team Jeana I
find her to be like such so immature and
like she takes no responsibility for her
life and it's like she her priorities
are so [ __ ] up you know yeah I'm not
team Jeana um but I sometimes understand
like her logic do you know any yet but
like I find like I feel like she's
really getting in with like the cool
girls now like everyone's like loving
her and I just like I really Stan Emily
I'm sorry like and I was just so
frustrated because I know there's a cool
Emily somewhere inside here's what I'm
realizing now the cool girls like just
love people when they're down and it's
like because Emily won't admit that
she's down and even in nerve and in the
one moment where she like was down
because of her weight Tamara liked her
and they like Tamra that's anime
using point and so like Gina is in a bad
place and so they just they like her
because like she's not strong I'm like
she can admit that yeah by the way
that's such a good call with the weight
thing yeah and so like Emily and
everyone just like wants Emily to like
admit that there's something wrong in
her marriage and in her life and like
she parties but like that's none of
their business and it's like they say
because she's not doing that they say
like she's not moving up she's not being
real with them but they just like want
her to like be psyche to subservience
yeah that is a brilliant analysis and
that it's so true like they want to feel
like they're in charge and they can be
in charge with people who are in a
vulnerable state
yeah and they they don't want some night
is there killing yeah and then and then
when they were at the gym like it was
like they were playing into the dynamics
that town was comfortable with yeah I
just want to talk about the gym scene
for a second because I need to get on
that machine okay I didn't think Emily
like one honey I just want to say she's
tall like it's not that big of a deal I
mean everyone acting like she's like on
the brink of morbid obesity like please
like well the numbers are the numbers
yeah the numbers are fine like I just
like no but the numbers are like fine
right now but yes check the hardest with
the American Medical Association
I am obese too like it's such [ __ ]
like Emily's fine she's fine right now
but like no one it's harder honestly for
me to maintain weight than to lose
weight so it's like if she doesn't make
a change he's just gonna keep gaining
weight so it's not like Oh in this
moment like you're in a horrible place
feel like you should make change your
lifestyle like that everyone was just
being like a little dramatic I mean
everything like that's the world like
everyone's traumatic she's in in
relationship to the world
Emily's fine no but I feel like last
season people were like calling her out
for her weight when she really was fine
but it's clear that this season like
she's gained weight she realizes it's
affecting her physically and mentally
and that's not good so make a change
yeah yeah she's like Verity in which
everyone speaks about it is a little
dramatic but I think only because of the
way that she speaks about it like
sometimes people gain win and they're
like I've never been happier yeah Tamra
said people usually gain weight when
they're like law like prolong states of
unhappiness but I also I didn't
necessarily agree with that like while
that is kind of an I only gain weight
when I'm half so happy that I just don't
I can't think about anything about ever
having to lose weight like I have to
miserable in order to do it yes so it
wasn't a fair judgment I just I feel
like I I feel on I'm just on Emily side
but I think that's a like a classic idea
which is that like you know you
emotional eating you know stress eating
so people associate that you're in a bad
place and so that's why people are
trying to like write her story for her
when you talk and it's also just not
that cut and dry all the time yeah you
know yeah it's sometimes you just can't
wait cuz you're hungry
no it's not it's no more complicated
than that or sometimes you just gave me
because you just don't have the time to
like make better choices anyway because
your husband's taking the bar and like
you're the primary earner and let you
take care of the kid and like you don't
have time to have it sit down and have a
salad you're gonna stop for tacos if the
drive-through yeah and you know what I
mean you know it I think they probably
said drive-throughs like where's the
shake or salad back yeah McDonald's also
I just Cameron Eddie's like judgmental
vibe but when she told him she ate tacos
like that's it like it was when she told
him she had cream and sugar and then she
said it was funny she was cream and
sugar
and she was like Splenda I said honestly
it wasn't a good commercial for cutting
it Fitness if I like ever really wanted
to go lose weight like that's the
opposite like that's not the environment
I want like I'm already ashamed enough
of my eating habits I don't need to be
shamed by you
but what's wrong with coffee cream ins
bunda no I had no idea she's a cream I'm
Jenna no okay I guess she could like use
almond milk but yeah and she said
Splenda it's like that's not what's
what's her you know like if she's on
this rapid um half of gaining weight
it's not because she's having cream and
sugar coffee you know the time when
people are it's like I can't drink dairy
it's like please that's my problem
so yeah but what else happened in the
episode with Shannon Kelly and her
family try so don't care yeah I was on
my phone I think I was calling in yeah
and then Shannon got the vaginal a shot
and I remember actually got an email a
little while ago from like a doctor's
office in New York asking if I want to
come in for a no shot and I was like now
I'm good yeah yeah nothing but I'm happy
for Shannon do this like Jesus he needs
the revitalization in her in her life
then all of it congregating at bronwen's
apartment like I don't understand the
apartment at all it's incredibly odd and
also Brahman and her husband like
implying that they want to have a
threesome with - Tamra yeah freaky
they're they're freaky I couldn't decide
how I feel about them and now I'm
decided I don't like them here's the
thing I have no
with them having 3/7 but when I was
starting to realize last night it's like
she wants to be like the cool she wants
to be a cool housewife she wants to be
accepted she obviously has this some
sort of complex like that she's admitted
herself and I think she like is using
this 3 something to like be like I'm so
cool like you know like said like it's
one thing to like skinny dip with your
friends and they kiss on the lips yeah
and like that's like what these girls
like to do and she's just like oh they
like that she's to another level
yeah and it's just like that was just a
really that's a dynamic we have not seen
yet before on the show like there's
absolutely no way Tamara's having a
threesome with them without Eddie that
would be crazy
that would be actually no way I'm crazy
that wouldn't happen
or like Brotman has a threesome with
maybe they have a foursome yeah it's not
a thinking couples seem swinging of
swinging yeah so it would be like brawn
minute Eddie and then mr. Brown would
but only Brahmin and Tamra wanna hook up
right so ok the two Real Housewives of
Dallas we had Luann's lingerie shower
okay like it's not a thing hosted by
Kari Juber which is so weird and just
makes me think carried uber is like
dying to get back on the show because
Leanne said some of the most horrible
evil things about her her family her
husband her daughter and here she is
like throwing a shower for her just as
she can get on TV it was really sad
honestly I really appreciated new Kerri
pointing out the extreme weirdness and
showing up in lingerie on Wednesday at
one o'clock like she's like of course
I'm not gonna wear my craziest lingerie
it's one o'clock also I just want to
give an honorable but honorable mention
to Brandi Redmond who looked incredible
incredible I love her and I'm loving
this burgeoning friendship between her
and Cameron it is it is really the
cornerstone of what's gonna be a great
season agreed but I need Cameron
Stephanie to work it out to figure it
out and I think what they have like why
it's their friendship is weird is
because they're actually really simply
you expect them to be so similar but
then the way that they go about
everything is so different because it's
like they both you know blonde Highland
Park like beautiful like great family
whatever but then it's like Stephanie
wears her heart on her sleeve and like
he's very open open and Cameron's not
like Cameron is that like you know sweep
sweep everything around like kind of
girl
like they just I think they don't
understand why the other is the way that
they are yeah and it's like they're
really fighting about nothing um and
they're both wrongs because they're
fighting about like perceived slight
right that say more about themselves
than the other person both wrong because
Cameron being upset that Stephanie went
to Carey's room to talk like she wasn't
talking [ __ ] she just went to talk the
fact that that's what she's harping on
from the trip it's so silly and she has
to let it go yeah and stephanie has to
stop saying the word whatever's
triggering Cameron into it like she's
obviously really self-conscious I've
ever done thinking that she's like cold
and bitter when she's claiming that
she's been this fun all along but nobody
ever gave her a chance
so Stephanie knows that's what she's
subconscious about it's the same way
that's brandi is self-conscious about
the word trashy so she needs to stop
saying that you're both wrong they just
need to like start fresh yeah because I
didn't understand like what even was the
issue there so it's obviously just
something that they're feeling and
nothing that we're seeing deandra's
meeting with Travis she looked
spectacular like the silk scarf around
her shoulders what was that yeah oh so I
just want to say this mean this episode
made me realize that the house husbands
of Dallas are an incredible group like
at first I was like wow Travis is a
[ __ ] P job for framing like great
advice I mean he put his shoes on the
bed which was just like not all not cool
but he's so come so far do you remember
him first season getting her list of
chores and now he's just like husband of
the year until Jeremy showed up at the
offices working for a stellar advice
working for free so [ __ ] supported
left holy crap totally and you know
who's next 20 to hear from is Bryan
Redmond because I do feel like he saw
himself on TV and is now a changed man
100% and even honorable mention for
court when they had that cute last
family scene and he was just so smiley
hanging out is my daughter have such a
good relationship like that's amazing
amazing and like usually men on the show
when they're like with their wife and
kids they have they think it's like cool
to like bicker and hit their wives down
and pretend like they don't want to be
there totally where it was just like
yeah and smiling but I've been watching
the affair and now I'm convinced like
that everyone is having an affair dudes
are you starting to like the affair
better um I just like to still hate
these two people like it's looser and
looser crowd 1000% Allyson is the
[ __ ] worst and so and like she like
she reminds me of like court over street
cuz she's like trout mouth yeah
I just like like I just can't stop
looking at her lips
justice for Helen she's the best
character and she gets she becomes more
of the stars she won an Emmy for after
the second or third season cuz it's like
her season Oh inter she is she's
everything she is yeah you don't even
know her because and it was like
watching the show obviously that makes
me convinced that like my husband's
having an affair too makes me really
nervous to have kids because their kids
are such brats Oh Jackie that kid who
pretended to kill himself in the first
episode oh my god evil and it's like and
then after the divorce they're only
worse and it's like you you you miss how
they were in the beginning it but they
sucked then to Teddy Whitney spiral out
yeah is it just kids on TV who suck both
or it's two kids suck like what are you
gonna do but how do you make sure you
don't have a Whitney but you're she's so
crazy
you're she is mean your kids are what
you make them you would think but Helen
seems like she would have done like a
good I guess they're fictional
characters but yeah but it's like Helen
until until the affair Helen was like
living in a fairy tale and we're like
her birth parents did everything for her
I don't know if she was like the most
present mother and Noah is a sociopath
so maybe that's why their kids turned
out that way because they had an
unpleasant parent and a father and a mom
with her head in the clouds yeah I don't
know it's just like these kids need to
start being scared of their parents
yeah honestly they need a spanking no
it's a skort example they were in
spanked and it shows yeah you know so
anyways a lot of these shows these days
I even started to watch euphoria for
five minutes like a while back and I
couldn't because like zendaya
disposition was making me just like too
sad to have kids also carries daughter
needs a serious [ __ ] attitude
adjustment oh my god way she was talking
to her mom like so [ __ ] rude I could
say but that was your fault like that
you didn't have a career like I'm I was
opening up to her like about a different
time period where I was just like I'm
coming on a woman to like be a homemaker
and stay in the house and how she kind
of regrets had and now she's trying to
make it was a very sweet sentiment well
that's like your fault like you did it
she was such a little [ __ ] I would have
slapped her across the face no like it
it was curiously it's a common theme in
everything that I'm watching where the
kids are [ __ ] they don't respect
their parents and it's truly making me
scared I was shocked by how rude the
kids were
and I mean just the daughter I can take
the daughters do but honestly I thought
one of the daughters friends is a
toaster and listen to this if it is
please show calories start with this
it's not cool to be mean to your mom it
makes you look like a piece of [ __ ] and
being disrespectful to your parents is
not cool
I know when you're sixteen you think
it's cool it's not be nice to your mom
she worked really hard and she like
gives you a nice house and a nice life
and now you're on TV and like the other
daughter who was like 12 and going to
like hit the bars or whatever and on a
weeknight like she was even said that
same daughter no this one's turning 21
the other one was like going on spring
break right oh yeah yeah yeah with a
little bikini yeah yeah okay real house
is Dallas is very good it's very good
I'm loving the gal oh and a cameo of
Tiffany yes Tiffany from season one I
don't know what happened to her leg and
her Keith Urban look-alike husband Feith
Bourbon um but I kind of liked her
except for blind loyalty Lee Julianne
was like a little boring to watch but it
was nice to see her again
yeah I don't miss her I don't miss her
it was nice to see her I'm glad she saw
your underwear um no wait I'm wearing
shorts okay I'm glad she's doing well
she's cutie she's a cutie
ah who else is around and then Deanna
Tantra and her business and Tantra did
not go to the Leon cherish our yandere
yeah but it's like it's Lance I'm gonna
invite her to her shower then why didn't
why did he enter invite her to her
birthday occasion no no she's she's not
gonna be DeAndre to her shower even
though they've been friends for like ten
years and they're in a rocky spot but
she's gonna make Harry do bird like I do
per host it and she's also gonna invite
Brandi who she left the trip on bad
terms with when she's actually on decent
terms with the engine she's also didn't
invite Kerry who she met it who she met
one week yeah it's just like that
doesn't make any sense also she's having
a groom shower bride shower a couple
shower like all her listing off all the
party she's gonna have she said twelve
parties before the wedding
that's crazy where did she go on her
bachelorette party it looks like it's at
a restaurant in Dallas like it doesn't
look like a trip it may be like the trip
of the of the season No
OC is going to Miami for the trip of the
season and it looks [ __ ] wild oh yeah
remember when they were in Miami toaster
saw them out to dinner like screaming in
a restaurant I don't know where the
Dallas trip is gonna be but it's not
Mexico's not the trip it was hit like a
small trap yeah a weekend getaway I
don't know either but I look forward to
it
I find the trip episodes to be so much
better of every franchise like the trip
episodes are the best because it's like
camp no and it's because we don't get
that clutter with family life yes be
fighting with struggling Kelly's mom
yeah yeah and it's like we we also don't
care about yeah most of that stuff okay
well that is our show for the week we
are heading to
tomorrow to kick-off la week so my show
is Sunday October 13th tickets available
: job calm and then we will have la week
episodes for you Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday and Friday
then Friday Jackie's heading home
Myanmar go heading to San Diego and San
Francisco for my shows tickets available
girls I'm calm and just look at it's
gonna be it's gonna be great so there is
no show Monday because we will be
traveling getting our stuff together and
recording the episodes this this week in
LA are not going to be live they're
gonna be posted on podcasts and YouTube
so it's a video and audio still but it's
just not live so starting Tuesday we
will get one up Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday and Friday so we will see then
we're so excited can you see us will be
Ali scenes and honestly the LA scenes
are some of the best teams I know
honestly the next time you see us we
might be at a movie premiere so look out
at TMZ
you just never know we love you guys
thank you for spending your morning so
that's we hope you enjoyed today's
episode thorn HS livestreams Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube so please subscribe to us on
YouTube give this video a thumbs up
leave a comment we're also available as
a podcast but you obviously know if you
are listening to us as a podcast right
now and that is available on iTunes
Spotify stitcher all the radio places
feel free to subscribe there leave a
five star review about how beautiful
skinny and smart we are we love you so
much have a amazing weekend don't drink
and drive be safe where your toes Marge
and tag us in your pictures bye
you